And you don't know where to look for
Local rl
Then make sure to save this video to what you should know
Charot
What you should know now
Then I don't know what that is
Shocking
I will miss brother kim atsensa today
That's okay because
These are seven
That you can use for
Your local rl
This one is from up
This one is from the central philippine
University
These are purely scientific papers
Related to Social Science
At hasaan
This one is from you
The latter is cultural criticism by and
But how about making a rrl
You need to know the scope
And objectives
of literature
What are those?
Topics or
Concepts you want to explore
Secondly you will now do a search
The ones
Websites that you will use
Keywords
Topics and how will you organize your rrl
You are about to make a
What should that be?
publication date
How can you tell if that
The literature you have selected is
Relevant to
Study or not
Are the ones you insult is credible
Be sure enough you choose which one
You will organize those
That you read
Is itthematic or chronological
Because what we used before is chronological
That's the one that's more
Applicable to
Study we are doing
Only and in the end you have to icite the sources
And then
Review and edit yours
Material if needed
Good luck and you will lock me in bye too